hi everyone I'm here with Grandmaster
Johnson International Masters
welcome girls thanks so much for
stopping by to talk to me a little bit
how do you feel the tournament is
approaching the end
really so upset was for me right
thank you I mean come back
and then I'm free because the last was
against humpy so only against there is
some chances
um what side the tournament's going well
but not for everyone maybe uh well I had
good life till yesterday and then I just
lost and okay I'm just looking forward
to playing good class for insurance so
we can finish in on good knots
you're both really young so you still
have a long way so it's like every
tournament you take it as a good
experience right to continue
hopefully getting better I'm looking at
your science and I want to laugh again
all right let's let's get to the serious
part questions can you tell me a little
bit about your hobbies is there
something specific that you like
okay for me it was boxing but I stopped
like a year ago maybe so I'm thinking to
to come back with with the lessons she
told me that in the
days ago when I asked you yeah with
Elizabeth is there anything else that
you like
I don't know other sports
at least traveling
oh traveling is always nice
uh but for now I guess just the sports
and staying home okay
well for me I'm really and I love you
yoga
yeah and um I was doing for three years
um horseback riding but I quit for like
because of the time management
I also want to
to go to do this again so like that
um can I do you have a favorite place
you have traveled to so many countries
do you have a favorite place
that you really like and you would love
to go back somewhere where it's not home
of course home is probably special but
um well recently I've been in Berlin I
love really historical places so Berlin
is like the mother of kind of cities so
I really love Berlin I think I can say
that this city okay
uh for me it's probably Singapore
yeah I lived there when I was 10. I was
studying in a chess Academy so I stayed
there for like two years and okay this
was the last time when I was in
Singapore so I want to visit again
I've never been in that side of
China I've asked you before this how
many countries approximately do you
think you've been to
about 50 for me well I'm using the track
the application being up
so it's like 36
. we still haven't we still yeah I still
have lots of
uh you've been playing chess ever since
you were kids both of you what age did
you learn to play
that was six six three five
actually we'll play it first time when
we were both seven yeah it was in 2007.
yeah we played world use in Turkey yeah
yeah
so still playing yes still together do
you have a nice memory when you were
when you're something that inspired you
to
continue playing not the not the person
but like something
why you stayed in the game was it your
parents that were more
pushing you to play chess or yeah for me
it was definitely parents yeah but also
okay I mean we I'm sure we both really
enjoy it yeah just to play and the first
two ways you should be enjoying then
someone else yeah sure do you have
something specific you like about Chess
why what do you like about it and what
what's your favorite thing about Chess I
know that's a weird question adrenaline
the adrenaline yeah
for me the feeling after you went so I'm
trying you know this tournament I didn't
get the chance to win still but okay
tomorrow last round I'll try
and also she's the she's the leader of
the tournament so
why not
interesting for me it's creativity I
don't know if it makes any sense
I think many things I mean yeah there's
a lot there's no specific reason it's a
tricky question I like to ask it
sometimes just to kind of give people a
sense of watch players
um like to do and what they fight for do
you have a game that's of yours that you
think was your best game or something
interesting happens or maybe you won a
competition after that game brought you
a big victory
that you consider your best game of your
career so far
wow I think it's hard to say I mean yeah
I mean we played many nice years but for
Me Maybe I played World Cup against
mariachuk I think it was
in 2018
so I play it with black there was some
nice silly and give I mean I think many
people saw it because there was also
some videos on YouTube and was some
people were just trying to commend it
and yeah that was a real interesting
fight so 2018 in Huntington's World Cup
it doesn't World Championship
s it's World Cup yeah world cup ah okay
okay
what about you um for me well also hard
to say but I think um like they're the
games against GMS that the winnings I
mean I well also then find them like you
know really amazing when you win and uh
if it's like young players gyms so in
Sergio last year I won a game against
evil
I found this game really fighting
because like there was up and downs and
then I won beautiful games
do you have any GM norms well ridiculous
and notes yet because I was like four
times half points uh shy so it's just um
well we'll see
someone has inspired me recently
um
regarding that
um saying that
if you you are going to get your GM
title when you play like the GM there
was a Grandmaster Maurice Ashley he
talks about this sometimes and I'm
struggling to get my I am Norm so this
is my final one so uh I hope I hope you
will get you will get something for you
on your way but thank you
um you became a Grandmaster
um what did it take for you to go from
International monsters to Grandmaster
would you feel that you did something
you know what was the final push that
got you to be able to reach titles
I guess
pandemia because you know I got my three
norms and I couldn't reach the 2500
rating and it was really hard because I
was always thinking about it like I have
to do it and it was always like you know
very close but I couldn't make it so
then when we had this pandemia time I
guess I had some rest and after that I
played the Grand Prix in Gibraltar which
I won and that was a tournament when I
got my rating yes
yeah so it took me like maybe two years
to reach the rating it wasn't easy do
you feel that the pandemic has affected
in a positive way but do you feel you
had more time for rest and rethink your
training because before you you had the
chance to play more tournaments but
um during the pandemic it was about two
years
you feel that you were able to spend
more time on chess
well maybe first month when everything
has closed yeah we didn't know what to
do so we're trying to you know just
continue the the lessons because no one
knew about the tournaments the dates so
you have to be ready like any time
uh but then but then it was hard because
you had no motivation like yeah yeah
actually for six months the old
tournaments were declined so there
weren't any plans yeah and also I really
hated online chess I mean this both
cameras yeah on two sides I mean I'm not
a fan of that you don't feel the how the
the opening is doing during the game
because I mean in life it's much better
of course as you can see like how it
feels so I didn't I didn't like this
time even though I had some time to rest
but still it wasn't nice
something
that is not very known or maybe
something that was perceived wrong and
like your friends you know
a lesson comes to my mind I don't know I
got married but I think everyone so
thanks for me I don't think
yeah I mean like after everything
happened I've been post I made a post
and I saved it on my page Instagram page
but still like some people are just like
texting me like are you like seriously
like you're married
yeah so so yes
or enjoying married life last question
last question
well she is nearly married so she can
answer first
um enjoying yeah
what can I say I mean no I mean it
didn't like we didn't have much time to
spend together because like after all
happened I mean I came here and almost
didn't see him for like 20 days it's
really hard so I want to go home yeah I
think Guna is already tired of hearing
because every day you know
looking forward to finishing the
tournament and going back home
yes and for me it's just like you know
nothing really changed so uh I'm just
more happier so like I love uh this is
new stage of my life yeah I like the
feeling that someone is waiting for you
you know it's not your parents or your
brothers or sis someone is just waiting
out of your family yes and he's like
even though we have like 11 hours
difference he's still like always online
checking for the games like it's nice
yeah I mean uh considering the the time
difference they can be like wake uh I
don't know like four to four a.m 3 A.M
like checking your game so it's yeah
just to talk to you after the game and
ask how are you feeling that's
I agree well thank you girls so much for
your time and good luck in the last
round and uh thank you tournaments
thanks